[Musique]
depuis l'entrée en guerre des États-Unis
en 1941 Hitler redoutait une invasion
sur les côtes-ouest de l'Europe occupé
par les Allemands
dès 1942 il s'était attelé à une tâche
gigantesque
construire un mur le long de
l'Atlantique constitué d'un ensemble
continuons de fortifications sur 6000 km
de la Norvège à la frontière espagnole
même si les Allemands soupçonnaient les
alliés de vouloir débarquer dans le
Pas-de-Calais distant de 40 km seulement
des côtes anglaises
[Musique]
les autorités allemandes avaient donc
réquisitionné des milliers d'hommes
travailleur libre requis du STO réfugiés
juif prisonnier de guerre pour mener à
bien cette construction délirante qui
nécessitera plus de 13 millions de
tonnes de béton
[Musique]
décidément cette fin d'année 1943 la
forteresse Europe semble solidement aux
mains des Allemands
et en ce début 44 ils ignorent toujours
quand et où le débarquement se produira
l'arrivée d'Eisenhower à Londres à
cependant confirmé Hitler dans ses
craintes d'une invasion à l'ouest
en 1942 il avait nommé maréchal l'un de
ses plus brillants généraux le populaire
Erwin romaine
à la tête de l'Afrique à corps le renard
du désert avait donné bien du mal aux
Anglais c'est donc naturellement que le
Führer charge cette énergie guerrier de
renforcer encore les défenses de la
forteresse Europe
[Musique]
début 1944 Romel est en France
l'aviation nazie mobilisée en Allemagne
contre les bombardements alliés il ne
pourra guère l'utiliser en Normandie
tout se jouera donc à terre et sur les
plages qu'ils jugent mal protégés
[Musique]
ils désirent établir une ligne de
défense continue en comblant les trous
entre les points fortifiés
[Musique]
parallèlement le maréchal demande
d'intensifier le minage du littoral
mais qu'est-ce qu'une mine
une goutte d'eau dans la mer en regard
des 1200 km de côte française qui
s'étendent du Pas-de-Calais à la base de
la Basse Bretagne
si les alliés sont unis rassemblés en
Angleterre
Hitler est loin des opérations dans son
QG de l'est près du front russe
pire fidèle à son habitude il divise
pour mieux régner
à l'ouest il a fractionné le
commandement allemand entre le maréchal
fondre runstett chef de tout le front
occidental et le maréchal Rommel
responsable des défenses côtières
or les deux hommes sont en désaccord
punchsted veut garder ses divisions
blindées à l'intérieur des terres pour
pouvoir faire converger toutes ses
forces vers les zones précises où auront
débarqué les alliés
Rome elle lui pense que l'aviation
alliée paralysera les mouvements de ses
troupes
il veut donc déjà répartir les blindés
au plus près des rives pour rejeter
l'ennemi à la mer si tôt débarqué mais
il n'obtient pas gain de cause
dès lors il se concentre plus que jamais
sur la protection des plages et dressent
des obstacles antichard
[Musique]
il exige aussi l'installation de
barrière Antibes et de chevaux de frise
constitué de morceaux de rails formant
de redoutables obstacles
[Musique]
il s'attaque même à la géographie du
terrain afin d'empêcher les parachutages
alliés et leurs mouvements de troupes
quand ils le peuvent les Allemands
inondent l'intérieur des terres côtières
[Musique]